[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
no one's here oh there we go zaki how
you doing
or ma'am or whatever
music
nice
fast click on stream gang what up
oh yeah
actually takes like
around five minutes for notification to
go out
hello from bulgaria what up bulgaria
just accidentally opened your channel
accidentally you were refreshing
constantly and you know we've come up
these are people that are checking their
subscription times
but it doesn't pick up from the
romanian gang is here
malaysia getting is here
when are you going to japan bro you guys
got to stop asking me because i don't
know okay their borders are closed for
foreigners
i wish i knew
[Music]
nice
how are you guys doing today
independence day in india
congratulations anyway
maraka it's a new game uh it looks
really cool i checked it out before and
then they reached out and asked if i
wanted to do a sponsored stream i'm like
hell yeah
so
we'll see how this goes
seems to be like a mix of genres
i played the tutorial and that's pretty
much it
[Music]
but it flows pretty well
naraka means hell i didn't know oh
[ __ ] that
nice beard yeah i'm freshly shaving
i'm back
my internet is dropping on and off
hope that doesn't happen when i'm
killing people
sorry about that
looks stable now
[Music]
yeah
yeah shave thank you
so
yeah did everyone get the notification
everyone here
i don't want to start playing
i look like a newborn baby yeah they all
come out with a stubble
that's the weather in uk gray and windy
as always
you got your ghost keyboard nice
i really love mine
i lost my flow
what is this song
what the [ __ ] is this
no
this place can stink it up
there we go this is it
and game solo
and
[Music]
all right just need to set up one side
can i see clearly without my glasses no
i'm
legally blind
staring at computers all day kill my
vision
i had headache for like two to three
days and i couldn't understand why
because i never get headaches for a long
time and then i realized i had like the
wrong prescription on my lenses like an
old version
because i just found them randomly
laying around so i was like
cool
it turns out i've been squinting and
giving myself headaches just from that
that's how blind i am
blind as [ __ ] why are you singing stop
singing i want background noise
[ __ ] help
sorry
i can't do laser i'm not gonna laser my
eyes if my vision is getting worse gotta
laser my eyes every year huh
stop it
and i don't know when i'm going to japan
stop asking me
coward
when are you lasering your eyes i don't
know
takes like half a second to put lenses
in i'm so sorry
i haven't done plastic surgery shut up
you want to fight me giant
is that where this is going
anything else you want to get off your
chest
i'm ready
yeah yeah you're tough now are you huh
that's what i thought
yeah you better back up
i need to channel this energy into video
game
which is too loud need to lower
[Music]
oh you think you can take me on
sure name a place anytime
[Music]
i don't laser my eyes i got laser eyes
[ __ ]
i'll burn you
ikea 4pm okay i'll be at all of them
meet me at the ikea rooftop
bring your finest katana
hmm
nao knight with a fitty thank you
we can't swear to pewdiepie where do you
play games with fans that's kind of nice
talk about books or do podcasts um
good ideas thank you
all right i had enough of this
i don't need my chat to slander me and
my good name we're playing
naduca
can you see
you can see but you can't hear
okay
i'm fresh out of this game
maybe i should do training
advanced tutorial
[Music]
start please thank you
i picked the boba girl
it just felt right
dodgers make
made during a dagger converter even more
powerful
oh i learned something new this is my
character
this is evil man
yeah this game is fresh check it out
link in description if you want to play
oh
this is just training mode
i'm not entirely sure where these things
are yet
stamina strike
composure okay for the katana
successful counter-strike combo will
recover health
i guess you find these while you play
how do i know which ones are good
let's practice the long sword
nice
got abilities
it's like an upgrade yeah i mean
i figured that
got him
i can change heroes from here
she's kind of cool
who's the best girl
not [ __ ] you that's for sure
i think i think we got it
we got it we got the best one
when i get my graphics again
here we go
you can grapple how far can you grapple
sick
that's kind of cool you stay mid-air
and you can hang
from there just checking out the angles
okay
i think i got the gist of it
hero skills
spirit slash and my old is ominous blade
i never played sick you know
properly at least
angles angles looks good
we established that
you can climb trees
that's always good
yeah oh they got boob physics did you
see that
check this out
they wiggle
they're just anti-gravity i love it oh
damn it's so fluid did you see that
that's kind of cool
you can slide jump
cool
[Music]
don't tell marx yeah i'm playing this
okay
we're good
that outfit i paid for that
got it in a crate
i don't like her you look dumb what
about the guys
it's kind of cool
[Music]
sure what if we customize her will be
she less ugly oh that's kind of cute
what about
you what a difference
just pick boba girl oh you're right i
don't know why i'm wasting my time okay
so what do you
i guess quick match
should do trio
start off in a party
that's probably the best way to go
customize the bubba
uh i tried it you can't really customize
the ball by it right now
i mean i i haven't checked yeah i
wouldn't know can't tell you about it
[Music]
this is my first match
this game isn't margin friendly i think
she would like it
uh oh lock it in
so
i pick where i want to spawn
where are we dropping boys he there's a
lot of buildings maybe here
that's good
uh mark the enemies one time how do i
mark enemies they didn't tell me that
that's easy i can do that spend
coins okay
sure
up team
it's a game too loud or too low let me
know
i like your armor it's cool
hey yo
we got mooks
my first match don't expect much oh my
god
are you [ __ ] kidding it's his first
is my first map too
they went with the boys all right
ping is middle mouse okay
all right here we go where am i
equal
we got a grappling hook nice
another grappling hook armor okay i'll
take it
that's cool area
where's the low
oh this is not gonna bode well is it
oh purple thing
oh we got stuff here oh this is one of
those trading things [ __ ] i don't have
enough got a gun
i got a gun
this is all garbage i need good stuff
what is this again
i got soul jade oh extra help nice
uh weapon bag upgrade nice
and this is what again respawn area i
think
samurai back to royale i think so
oh great sword nice we'll replace that
with the
that looks good
nice
grappling hook
okay
where are my teammates
i need to move we need to move [ __ ]
so if i mark
i need to go there
how fast is it closing
they're telling us let's go
[ __ ]
what up
you got any gear
oh i got a cannon
what i love that
dude i got a [ __ ] cannon
i'm gonna blast these fools
okay let's go
someone's shooting me
is my teammate shooting me what the [ __ ]
shooting me
oh you are
we gotta help him
whoa
whoa 420
baby [ __ ] get [ __ ]
die [ __ ]
[ __ ] my cannons out
yo can you do something
yeah get [ __ ] [ __ ]
kill [ __ ] get the trip
repair the cannon
thanks for the help gamers we gotta get
going
yeah yeah you guys go ahead and loot
after doing nothing
okay
all right we gotta move
i think
no we have time man
ah they're shooting me
what the [ __ ] is he doing kuroyami
you guys go ahead
oh the cannon is so good
how do i heal
all right they [ __ ] them up
thank you poor
[Music]
all right let's go gamers
yeah i didn't i didn't see the hotkeys
okay
oh
oh [ __ ]
now they're shooting me with kenneth
oh it's so [ __ ] funny
[Music]
quadra kill [ __ ]
who's shooting me with a cannon anyway
i need weapon repair
uh
oh [ __ ]
oh no i miss
we gotta help is that weapon repair
i don't repair my weapon again this are
now repairing all right
all right guess i'll help
[Music]
nice are we still fighting
because i
we're still fine
invincible thank you
i don't think i need this many
references
oh this is source armor
a weaponry chest which one
nice thank you
[Music]
yeah
we're back in action baby
nice do i have armor
armor already quit okay
love the cannon
range defense head defense nah i already
have it
okay
we should probably get going right
we're in the circle
just keep learning that
repair my katana
thank you
yo slack
oh we got some people
oops
get [ __ ]
hey hey leave some for me
it's their bridge in this game nah i
don't think so
thank you for asking though
yeah they have to be bots they're so bad
some of them
oh ho
no i'm just kidding yeah you're right
this is similar to any existing game i
played fortnite
all right
nah
nah oh
are they attacking us no
i wanted to enter the house
someone's they've been looting here
hold up that's the edge
oh yeah and there's a golden circle too
oh we got people
we got action this guy
oh get [ __ ]
so poor as well
my item bag full
yep
beautiful i like it
we'll see how it progresses
[ __ ]
i want that like oh that's how you open
doors nice
where are we
we should go to celestra
i think you can well run yeah
where do they want to go
oh we got a poor soul
you're dead
you can't run from me you get cannonball
[ __ ]
get [ __ ]
hell yeah
all right she wasn't entirely poor
okay this temple has to be good ray
oh
i see epic
give me this
pistol
[Music]
oh
give me
oh legendary spear
we about the [ __ ] [ __ ] up
so there's a golden circle there's like
free stuff you can get there
i also need to remember i can trade
stuff i think
from yeah these
if i go there
i don't know who's [ __ ] shooting
how do i get there
[ __ ]
oh someone's trying to kill me
this looks like an actual player
because he has armor and [ __ ]
wait i lost my spear i haven't attached
it
what happened to my spear
this will do for now
if he blocks you you can lose your
weapon okay
i'll go dagger then
oh we got one more
not killing it with the dagger not gonna
lie
all right all right
oh i can't repair [ __ ]
oh
well don't mind if i do
how do i get the armor like they have
like blue armor and [ __ ]
oh that's five
give me armor
i understand game oh we got people
it's the only one oh god no no no
no no i'm innocent
hold up
nice
oh epic pistol
let's go glory is mine
girl i did the most amount of damage
most amount of healing most amount of
rescues most amount of kills most of my
bubba let's go
gg boys
zero depth
on top baby
yeah
nice
oh battle reward
give me
what level am i
three
we just gotta keep playing
i should have gone the spare back i
agree
i forgot to mark people [ __ ]
easy
ein harrier
what stupid name sorry
yeah it's like a
battle royale
samurai's
fighting style
i'm not sure
we go second game
all right
all right we're all the good stuff bubba
girl
give me the good stuff
oh we got cannon
all right
yep
uh yep definitely wanted to
oh you can wallow in sick
i guess i'll take the katana for now
uh-huh armor for now
maybe in the cave there's good stuff
oh nice
maybe up there
thank you
this is where we picked last time i
should know this area
a bunch of [ __ ]
dagger
i like the controls
this moon
i'm not entirely sure like if i'm
picking up the right stuff
oops i picked up something
oh so these are my other weapons okay
let's see that
cool
oh there we go
yes
i'm ready baby
maybe yeah let's do that oh
oh
oh ho ho
okay
where are we going
[ __ ] you scared me
where the [ __ ] did he go there you are
yeah come up here
come up here
ah she's hacking
yeah heal all you want [ __ ]
i'm almost dead too
never mind
oh
yes she had a better cannon
sweet
i hear someone
but where
no i failed
what is that oh yes
there you are
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] they hit me
i'm trying to mark him
what is he doing monkey boy
hell yeah
so good zero deaths baby
you can't touch me
my teammates
i should probably get going
oh what's this shiny
a bounty
defeat mo self oh you're dead myself
[Music]
okay they're not far
oh
none day
my camera is glitching
what is it doing
hey
the boys are back
looks okay for me
oh i saw it it blinked off for a second
overheating
oh
we got pro players
oh he's got the cannon he must be
amazing
he blocked
old old old here comes
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is happening
i killed someone what
hell yeah
i'm the new leader killer hell yes
oh we gotta kill him too
invincible
did she just call me sam
love that
simpin
okay
circles closing
we're doing good
camera's flickering don't tell me oh
i have to hit a bell
i did it
oh this is the trading area there we go
give me
yes
excuse me i'm shopping over here
get [ __ ]
cool now we can shop some more
i just can't be stopped i'm actually low
on health [ __ ]
help
why am i blocking
where are we going
that's the hardcore action of the game
playing us
stop running
oh that was my kill
hold up i gotta hear
rip camera man
oh
did it grow
up
it was dangerous
yeah
all right
all right boys what are we doing
what is this
we good
let's go if there's a golden circle
closing because i want to get that [ __ ]
in two minutes
master climber
what did you find
that's
cool you have a ton of our weapons you
can hold
whoa what is happening to my camera
oh [ __ ] we're gonna attack
cowards
oh oh
okay no fall damage
bro i'm looting
nice we got better armor
rip camera
rep
oh we're back
we're outside the circle now i think
right on the edge mate
oh hello
taking a lot of damage here we're
switching up
the cannon gang
can't escape cannon gang
nice
they're so bad dude
dude stop stealing my kills
doing everything here
i'm the one with the pointy hand i
deserve respect
okay
can you die in this game well other
people can
you see
but i
cannot
consider that oh here golden circle
let's go
mine
give
we're shooting
where's my goal
yes
oh
stop it
knock it out
oh i see you
have we blocked at the same time
come on [ __ ]
get [ __ ]
up
is there anything else
so the circle charges up what happens
when it's charged up now
it disappears okay
oh
repeating crossbow kind of want to try
that
oh rich gang
everyone bad at this game yeah everyone
except me thank you very much
i'm repeating crossbow
oh
look at that damaged
[Laughter]
i'm trying to escape
tree gang
this is a
musket gang
bubba girl oh look at that most amount
of kills most amount of damage most
amount of healing most amount of
resources most about a bubble
he died from the trees he's with the
bees
look at that beautiful
beautiful
uh we level up our proficiency
nice we get stuff ooh much stuff
ha ha talent
what is this
oh
spend money yeah
absolutely oh i gotta go with
more
more pay to win
come on
this
i is this isn't how they look like
anyway
[Music]
nice i'm level four
i think you play more against people
with level five
my camera is having a bad day man let me
turn it off for a bit let it rest
how's that
you can't see me but here i am
game 38
should i get something from this oh
thank you
all right we got to climb
trees
remind me to climb trees
you guys want to check it out the game
is out now link in description
[Music]
not okay
drop
right in the gut
travel more than 500 meters easy peasy
my computer's lagging
what happened
since i removed the camera
hello
everyone skins are so ignoring me and
then you got me
oh
just check out the leaves
realistic looking
nice
here we go again
give me the loot
i don't see any loot
i'm toast gamers oh
i got a dagger we're good
oh bounty
i don't think so
oh
yes we got the cannon
easy win
oh nice
oh
oh green there's green boys
nice
epic
cool
oh
oh epic katana
let's go
already looting mate
oh i like that
you can charge it
can't have bad camera quality if you
have no cam
been doing it right
i'm doing it wrong
did someone in my team kill someone
sounds like it
oh oh they got oh canon boys
finish the kill
staying
sorry sting
sorry girl
i forgot to loot them
yeah give me your money
oh yeah you're looting them psychosis oh
i'm sorry
idiots
what do we do now gamers
oh look at these acrobatics
oh they're already up
oh climb trees [ __ ] where i gotta climb
trees so what am i doing
oh broke gang
[ __ ]
myself
that's a tree climb it
tree climber gang
another tree let me crime it
yeah
yeah climb that tree yeah
i see another tree
[ __ ]
cannon gang
get fought
wasted
steeler
how dare you
where are you going
give me money
my money my money
oh
head defense
let's go back to the chest
these are the shoes
i got my cannon
there you are
i want it what does this do acquire a
soul jade of random quality
doesn't seem that good but i'm tempted
what do i get
what what i get i should have upgraded
instead [ __ ] now i'm broke
[ __ ]
oh here they are
uh
landing a shot and then with with your
bow leave some unable to sprint oh
that's for the kid
don't have a boat
bogang
someone's trying to shoot us
cute
master climber
bow
common bow
nah
oh what was it
oh yeah
beautiful
it's like a light bulb
what up gang
golden circle here
let's go together
any full damage question mark oh that's
sick
oh
oh there are people that people climb
the trees climbing trees quick climb in
the trees
all right i'm gonna snipe with that
cannon
almost
oh all right
[ __ ] i'm always out of range
oh my kill 100 thank you
any bows
nope
what is that again grab free treasures
while you can
free treasures
don't care
free treasures oh shiny
oh chest chest the sun
closed
bow
okay
hey hey teammates help me
idiot
what up team
there's 20 alive life
norwegian for sure yeah i could smell oh
another norwegian
climb the tree
yeah [ __ ] him up
poor lad
oh another one
she's got umbrella
[ __ ] owl
invincible
hell yeah that's me
i should also recover
what up this parker
yeah [ __ ] him up he tight now
it's cannon time
cannon time
oh i'm broken
[Music]
hey
i have a lot of money
what do i see my money
my money all right let's go to one of
those money places then
oh people
hey he's melt
get [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
finish with cannon
oh the can is so funny
why is there an umbrella here
mine
all day oh we got a bone now let's try
and check it out then
yes
uh bag upgrade
that i hear someone
where are they
oh cannon gang have to kill
yeah where you going ow
last shot finish her
yes no [ __ ]
yeah i got her
not a kill still
not a kill seal
joint
anywhere
you can't run
ah [ __ ] kill steals
can't believe it
epic katana don't mind if i do
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah gimme gimme gimme
advanced hero
let me try the bow
we're in the circle
we're just chilling
oh it's just golden circle here
what do we get free stuff
i want it
[Music]
same
are my teammates boss as well because
like
they just follow me they're very polite
and we're outside the circle as well
should probably get going
oh bridge sad
starting to like the game
our gamers were in
they'll never see me
but here i am
oh there's only us left
there's only one party left we should
just find them then oh we won
that was tough
oh most amount of the kills
most amount of damage and most amount of
everything
gamer did it again
they said it couldn't be done am i level
five yet
it was climbing the trees yes you're
right absolutely
ho ho
go fight in the herald's trial mode it's
impossible to achieve zero that's there
uh not for me but thank you
[ __ ] i gotta fart what's the protocol on
streams never mind too late
oh we got a treasure
um
level five okay nice
let me do a quick
camera check
we're bringing them back see how he's
doing
hello how are you
i'm gonna reset the game as well
i can't tell if my computer is
having a stroke
protocol to fart
the streamers fart surely they must fart
i can't be the only one
i look 20 without a beard yeah
i can do this one really nice now
never mind
just flew out of my head
it is
[Music]
[ __ ] clara what did she do
okay i got a pp
[Music]
but now i think the real games begin we
played through the tutorials
the quest for zero deaths
continues
bareback
[Music]
[Applause]
peggy you want to say hi
to screen
somebody
what uh
um
paris
can kill
you but they're very good
all right who are
100 egg you want some prayer hey guys
yeah
come here
i'll share my pair
man
they'll love it
oh tongue gang
look how cute he becomes
as soon as there's food around
how do dogs do that
you'll have your turn
lots of love from turkey hey max around
thank you very much
okay
sorry
oh i got edgar hair on my pear that's
disgusting
proceeds to eat
you can bite it you know
here
bite it stop licking it
no bro fight it
oh my god you're so dumb
eat it
he's like oh i can bite it
oh
you got it
edgar versus pier
come on you can do it
you can do it
yeah oh
yeah
come on bite it
bite it here i'll help you bite it
bite it i'm holding it still it's slimy
i don't wanna
bite
bite it stop licking it
bite give shove them up you can bite
show him how tough you are
oh my god you don't lick you don't lick
it how does this dog survive anywhere
you can't eat anything
are you done
are we done here
you're done
okay you can leave now
you can leave now you're just gonna be
annoying
go
bye
everyone say bye
hey doll yeah you go yeah that's right
you leave
come on
he's so funny
watch my hand
wait it says i'm level three but i'm a
little
oh my title is level three
okay now it's herald's trial
so now we'll play against
people so
yeah we'll see how this goes [ __ ]
[Music]
my computer can't handle this it's just
like
i forgot i need to add my
i think i guess i have the wrong
settings
pairs don't get that sticky it's fine
guys download the game so i can play
come on
i gotta wait one minute that's too long
[Music]
oh i did the daily quest
yeah
oh level six baby dude we're going
places
oh we can open chest
ho ho
sick
oh
open one please
i'll share that
uh
open another one
yeah
worth it
oh
another one
come on
come on fingers crossed
more string
another one
come on
channel
channel the energy
good fortune will be bestowed
boiling
another one
should i do
i want to do it
[Music]
i want a cute outfit for her what do we
got this oh yeah
yeah
what are your talents though
[Music]
oh
yeah
uh reduce the amount of energy required
to dodge increase the kaplan speed
increase the amount of rage you generate
when you take damage increase the amount
of
uh
enjoy discount
increase the rate of which
no
this one
oh one percent
all right didn't i get a skin i got a
skin didn't i
oh
baby it's got two panthers
that's sick
all right i got
skin yo
oh yo it could
what else i got cannon cannon skin that
would be so sick please
oh i'm broke oh pink pink cannon i want
it
[ __ ]
hold up
hold up i gotta i gotta spin
i gotta spend money
i gotta do it
i gotta do it i gotta do it
my card info
i gotta do it i must do it i gotta do it
i gotta do it
authorized
gotta do it
it's been authorized
where's my money
waste my money there it is
oh we're opening
[Music]
buy it
ah ah oh don't show [ __ ] they showed
god [ __ ] it
all right boxed i boxed my account name
rip oh no
how do i spend money
how i spend money
oh
ah
but i already
bought
how i'm
take
you took
got it got it
there it is
use
yeah
come on come on charge your energy
open one
another one
oh
damn it it's her
ridicule another one
oh it's ugly [ __ ]
damn it i want cannon's skin
i want pink cannon skin
i need it i need it
oh
oh crimson in kinsen
another one
oh the devs
they're like hey so we're going to use
our resonation now the queue time will
be a little longer we're working to
solve the issue thank you for letting me
know that and um
oh we got it
another one
i didn't know they were watching
face
another one
i'll just switch gamewood but i gotta
open
cute
not her color though
another one
oh she can bound now i like that
how many can i get for all this
oh my god oh my god oh my god
should i do that
92 dollars
what else would i spend 92 dollars on
i needed to buy some more hue lights
[Music]
don't really need hue lights
ninety two dollars that's a lot of g
fuel
that's fair
but i can get g fuel for free
hold up uh hold up i'm thinking through
it
you get a lot of kombucha kombucha is
way too expensive
then again
i am rich give me
50 treasure yes
all of them at the same time
oh
oh thank you max harriet
i just opened one
ah that's gonna take forever to open
no no no no no
open 10.
oh 10 [ __ ] we're opening 10.
oh oh
give me another color what's the line ah
purple oh
oh cute
we already have that [ __ ]
squeeze cheeks
oh
again
come on
[ __ ] purple
porcelain bow i have all of this how
rich am i again
oh my god
wolf and pete
share it
oh
that looks sick
okay
all right i think that's enough again
come on come on purple
bloody grin
all right we weren't lucky that time
that's all right that happens i think
yeah that's a good time to end it
it was fun but oh my god damn it [ __ ]
oh god
what have i done
i have eight more i have eight more i
have eight more i have eight more
again
oh
flynn took
again
a gratitude again
bow again
corpses again
boiling again
all female characters bow again
you're right again
ah damn it i have that [ __ ]
all right
[Music]
all right we got anything cute
give me the cute
i want the cute
um we got the flint hook
i'm more of a cr the crimson looks
cool well now it's the one
oh we got the the room man
i can't really see it there it is that's
cool i like that
gesture
cute
leg
and
arm uh bow
and like an arm thing
emo
i like this one
five more for legendary
you're telling me if i buy for five more
i guarantee you'd get legendary
[Music]
well i mean i got it
i'm not going to do it
[Music]
but then again
maxirian donated 50 so i think it's only
fair
that i spend those fitty
and i think he that's what he want
this is for him his honor
[Music]
just find more just buy more
okay five more
open one
boiling
no no no
no no no five more oh seven more maybe
seven more
yeah seven more yeah
get out of here ugly
[Applause]
is that good was that the one was that
the
epic that's actually cute
whale
oh baby
there it is okay stop
stop
okay you're gonna look better now
hopefully
she got that one and that one but we
also got oh baby
oh that's oh that's sick
from young age kuruma would always dream
of where
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
which one is cute
[Music]
yes
cat girl taking over how do i make it
there we go
okay
we should play something else then uh
[Music]
are all the eu servers struggling
that's bad timing did you guys break the
servers what did you do
it was worth it look at the butterflies
thank you
someone get it
she looks sick
damon i'm gonna pretend that i didn't
read that
can i change which server i'm on
[Music]
no i know what you meant i know what you
meant me
all right what's bloodbathing
oh this one works let's play this
bloody
i'm that that [ __ ] i felt the dopamine
something hell yeah
i'm a new man
absolutely
oh god what happened to her face oh
thank god
all right what is this game mode i
actually didn't look we got 11 11
players
shoot
our voice is a little annoying i'm not
i'm not gonna lie but the cat ears
evens out it evens out
at least i'm the cutest
look at that look at my ankle it's
my team stance
me and the boys
so this is so low
but i'm not sure what the game mode is
it said blood something
the map is way smaller okay
i only have
a sword
you're about to get [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah blocked him
get [ __ ]
finish the kill
whoa that's my ability
okay that's kind of cool
and i can heal as well that's my old
everyone gets good weapons okay that's
cool
oh someone's using their old
[ __ ]
sarah that's broken
i did
[Music]
come here come here schmuck
so sorry
whoops
save me
cute
no
nice
cute
get [ __ ]
why am i not moving
to the riffle baby
let's go
oh i'm i'm a goner
bounty has begun
i'm trying to escape
that did not work
is she moaning every time i don't you
tell me
this is like death match that's cool
good for practice
where did she go
so sorry
how jesus
me
cat girl on the prowl
looking for prey
bro just stop
come back
ow [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm almost dead
[ __ ]
no she grappled me
come back here coward
yeah the sounds is a bit sus i'm not
gonna lie
jesus [ __ ] christ chill out
[Music]
oh my [ __ ] god
destroyed by that guy
kurumi means walnut nice
use the armor
i thought i had a charge
where everyone got
everybody dead
oh
spotlight that guy is so [ __ ] lp
must kill him
dude i'm trying to kill the best player
you're [ __ ] me over for what
no
mghb you killed me i can't believe it
yep
all right tree gang
he can't run the trees
tree gang
[ __ ] i'm not intriguing
oh my god tree gang over
tree gang over tree gang over
return to the trees return to the trees
return to the trees
[ __ ]
can't always treat gang
do you think male characters moan 2 yeah
obviously there's nothing wrong with
that
tree game
all right here we go
oh what the [ __ ]
is that is alt
all right steady steady tree game
they can't see me but here i am
3.99
oh
finally we got that [ __ ]
nice feeling
tree gang
some call it camping
but who camps in treats
three gay
oh fools
[ __ ] he spotted me in the trees
impossible
what is that weapon
that's a [ __ ] drill
i will live
tree gang
[Music]
he fell for the oldest trick in the book
[ __ ]
oh i'm [ __ ] this boy up
finish this guy off
no
oh blocked him
oh you want to hold now
[ __ ] get [ __ ]
blocked
[ __ ]
tree gang
how do i get up here
kind of struggling
[Music]
outplayed
all right then
where did they go
you don't see me
oh fool
yes no
match over okay that was good
i won
nice
cool
top rank
nice
not bad
top of leaderboard
so these are actual players
sweet
uh let's see if we can do battle royale
mode
hey then
hidden treasure
okay
i'll give it a minute
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been a while since i enjoyed a good
battle royale
this seems interesting in them
that i can get into
see if you want to check out the game
link is in the description
use it to download
okay it looks like herald trails is up
off the grid but bloodbath works so epic
i enjoyed it anyway
because of the moons no
that's this bonus
bonus
gotta play this with joey yeah
i think this is his kind of game isn't
it
[Music]
nice
perv man's game no cultured man's kind
of game
tree gang kind of game
just me
all he needs
at level 69 you can play naked
wow
all right i know this um
i know this gal now find the trees oh
god there's no trees we're dead
we're doomed
okay
all right tree game
ignore ignore temptation go
embrace tree gang
nope get up
that's too [ __ ] funny
[ __ ]
he thinks he's safe
three gang
okay okay i'll stop i'll stop i'll stop
i'll stop i'll stop i'll stop it you're
cool you're cool you're cool you're cool
you can stop
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
how dare you
[ __ ]
i gotta repair
don't shoot me i'm repairing i can't hit
not tree gang
3.99 oh [ __ ]
oh you fool
[Music]
um
this [ __ ] coward
come on they barely hurt each other
that's how you pro
[Music]
all right
come on coward
mate
[Music]
[ __ ] you found me congratulations
return to the trees
quickly
you'll never find me here
stop it stop it
you walked right into trap
all right mate you starting to piss me
off here
oh she's lucky
get fog
ow another one [ __ ]
no
there's no not enough trees in this baby
what is that is that yeah is that a
trebuchet oh we got some action
oops
[ __ ]
i'm sticking with cat girl
i'm loyal
and i snipe from here
come on
oh how who dares
who dares
this is my strength
all right [ __ ] it
we're getting in there boys
hey
that's definitely my kill come on
she saw through my trap
to the trees
[ __ ]
definitely didn't steal that
to the trees
hey
[ __ ] i'm low durability
stop moving so much
[Music]
hey
all right fine
no in the circle nice
[Music]
come on kurumi
come on baby
chat simply for kurumi i see
all right
the winning strat
the winner strat
shoot the umbrellas
i see you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is umbrella doing
i'm missing all my shots
[Music]
are you serious i do all damage
walnut gang come on
umbrella gang
get [ __ ]
[Music]
block that [ __ ]
can i finish him off please
there you go
oh okay that was nice got a trip
let's go
is
whoa that's cool
no i was gonna [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
all right gg
all right so i won another one sweet
bubba girl very popular
okay
they just uh tell me
they fix their servers we can play
harold's trial as well
gotta give that another go
[Music]
thank you
based on rocket dave thank you
we got some practice in it kind of
worked out
uh
yeah
no
okay
she's saying that
she thinks she's interesting is that
what you said
just change back to english curious how
she sounds like
oh we got mike gang
nihongo english
did i change it
yeah
all right kurume is english now let's
see if it's equal amount of moaning
that's still
japanese i guess you can't change game
hey
am i using contact lenses yes
all right oh [ __ ] we gotta
focus this is our first actual game
well
garbage
nice
garbages
is that what i think it is oh i'm so
excited i miss her japanese already
excited yeah i would be excited if i
literally didn't didn't get it a second
ago
can i ping it for my teammates
oh thank you i won't make the same
mistake twice
okay
she sounds like reese witherspoon from
legally blonde
the [ __ ]
swap you out mate
nice
it's not a
no that's what i drop
i mean i can try
oh
huge
nice
these pistols then i never use the
pistol
it's like i said it runs oh
we get you my gamers what's brewing
excuse me
it's like i said
things always happen to geniuses true
it's not wrong
speaking of uh cute girls and geniuses
what was it einstein said it was like
if you do something tedious time will be
really slow but spend 15 minutes with a
girl pretty girl and it will go really
fast
i got a cannon [ __ ]
[Music]
you shall be healed
nice
[ __ ] him up
stolen stolen
einstein was a simp
just saying
nice to be the one being healed for once
confirmed he definitely said that
that's how you explain relativity
according to einstein
that's how actually that was a direct
quote from his original publication
guys all right i figured out this
groundbreaking physics theory
imagine being with a hot girl time just
push
okay
now
all right i guess in a german accent
ah
imagine
i don't [ __ ] know what i'm saying all
right loaded
oh i complete a quest
epic
there's austrian my bad
sorry austrian
einstein's ghost
it's like i said good things always
happen
yes oh i'm doing good
someone's shooting us
come on don't be scared
wow
indeed
now i can cause trouble great sword is
yeah kind of op not gonna lie
i like it it's cool too i like the skin
i got for it
oh i'm going to see free guy tonight
jack's in it i mean ninjas in it
i'm uh i'm hyped for that
the healing may begin
okay so how does this work again i can
link it to my teammates and then i can
teleport there and do damage while i do
it that's kind of cool
i like her abilities
i think we found the best girl hey pills
just wanna thank you for continuing
youtube over the years i remember being
11 watching your live streams while
coding for fun now i'm a cyber ops for
the military still watching you as a
program bro
cyber ops
that sounds awesome
oh i need
i need
here
all right then tdm's in it too
i i can't wait to see them i can't wait
i saw jax uh it's dubbed that in italian
and he sounded so strangely much like
him was really funny
oh and also ryan reynolds in it i guess
attack our enemies or i shall make you
regret it
what the [ __ ] are you doing
she's ceiling stop her
jesus christ did that mean
yeah do it do your umbrella thing there
you go
locked it
up
oh pokemon is on sorry
can't wait
i i will say i mean i would be
i have no right to speak about this but
it did seem like some of them jack was
really good
but some of them sounded a little bit
like an ad read when they were doing the
lines but then considering me on south
park i think you know they did amazing
what are you doing
oh yeah this is the quest
bro i was so nervous that were my idols
okay what am i supposed to do
let's not bring that up they were
amazing that's it and story
uh yeah taika what tt is in it too dude
he's everywhere
man can't stop
a jade bag upgrade you took it how dare
you
what are you doing
oh he disarmed me [ __ ]
so what happens to my great sword there
don't take it don't take my great zone
oh my god
would you do movie rolly farmer to me no
absolutely not
i've done embarrassing myself
hello
this [ __ ]
steals all the kills
greatswords right there
oh
blue shirt kid better than blue shirt
guy where
yeah i've declined a lot of movie stuff
i can't do it too awkward
but
free guy would be tempting
because ryan reynolds
lava
he's shooting me i'm there you
don't even try it
oh god i'm getting [ __ ]
you shall be healed
the short-range
cannon makes me laugh dude
any remedies for stuffy blocking us you
came to the right place
i don't know blow your nose [ __ ] if i
know
i used to take those nasal sprays but
then you get addicted to them it's kind
of like lip balm you always use lip balm
your
lip all forever dry
same with nasal spray you use nasal
spray nose forever climb
rip
my future is protected oh we're here
oh she used to think
stolen
i mean if you're not gonna take the
stuff and
i mean if that was going to take the
stuff i mean
i mean if no one's going to take the
oh oh oh oh oh
we got it back at last
it's like i said good things always
happen to geniuses
do i have a musket no
hello i was looting
sorry dft
nice
destroying these fools
oh she's getting [ __ ] geez the great
sword man
oh
i guess the young do know better easy
holy [ __ ] we destroyed them
hell yeah
i wish i could play more i gotta go
cinema
i enjoyed the game check it out link in
the description use a link to download
naraka
it's a good battle royale with the bubba
thank you for joining the stream as well
free guy i just said it
i just said it
should i do one more
i'm checking mines here
we're ending it on a high though
[Music]
[Applause]
okay one more
i'll change the japanese [ __ ]
i should make my own knives yeah i i j
honestly i just want a custom pewdiepie
one that'd be so cool
but
yeah all right kurumi
wherever dropping boys
it's here i think
there we go
yes
and just one more
yes one more
for the road
yeah
i am good
in barca what does that mean
impact
pink hair looks kind of though i'm not
gonna lie
but i got the kitty ears
so win by default
do you have to wear masks in the cinema
i don't think there's a mask mandate in
uk anymore
um
it's good because i always forget mine
and then i have to walk back but
i mean
at stuff like groceries and stuff i kind
of prefer
to have it
i kind of like the masses because it
makes me more private
don't hate it
but i'm glad it's not mandatory
we met a girl that uh so obviously
wanted to take a photo with marzia and
not me but i was like oh sorry i don't
do selfies anymore and she was like okay
but i didn't ask for one with you [ __ ]
i wanted marzia
well she doesn't either according to me
where are my teammates am i [ __ ] if i
meet someone
no we're near
but other than that everyone's been
super chill
uh meeting people
i enjoy it so much more
like a friendly hello
so much more pleasant
i think uk are pretty chill british
people
and i don't get the screamers anymore so
it's all good
uh
how are we doing items decent
i get recognized a lot i would say
probably
the screamers younger fans yeah
but not always
oh hello
oh
[Music]
oh you got [ __ ]
oh absolutely destroyed where is she
come back up
come back here
[Music]
oh
hey hey you don't have to take
everything
what is this
long sword i didn't know that was a
thing
she has cat ear or sven here now you're
asking the real questions
i'm not sure
hey
[Music]
[ __ ] intriguing
do i sneak past in the cinema marcia
does she always has a pasta pocket
kind of like napoleon dynamite
are they attacking my teammate yeah
i want it on him
[ __ ]
ow
stop running oh my god
i sneak into streaming here
you never know when you get a snack
yeah use my grappling hand
hey
bro gang
wasn't there good stuff in the case
looted
oh boys we gotta get moving
oops
monkey gang
are there enemies
mine
[ __ ]
it's for daggers isn't it
how many people left that 40 where is
everyone
oh
right by the edge baby
nice
what is that what is that is that
because we're on the edge oh [ __ ]
i never been close to the edge before
[ __ ] scary stop it
stop it
spooky circle
you want to go here
good idea actually
oops
it's looted
i'm back
we got enemies
oh my [ __ ] god
that sounds
beautiful
[Music]
popcorn nitros nachos and pretzel bites
with cheese dude you went go hard
oh epic cannon love the cannon
cannons deal less damage fire two
projectiles give me that [ __ ] let's go
double cannon time
oh it's happening
an epic one
pistol shot damage now
great sword i don't have the great sword
i do have the right sword
i like to get the popcorn
with the
i gotta buy a
ah
salted popcorn yay pepsi cherry flavor
max of course
and then you get more teases and you mix
it with the popcorn baby
who you
i don't even know why they offered sweet
popcorn here
i don't know what's wrong with this
country
they also offered honey roasted nuts
which is just nuts
oh
oh yes yes please
long sword the third strike in a combo
unleash a sword and
[Music]
give me that
i love caramel popcorn though well guess
what you're wrong buddy
you're just wrong
i'm using the great sword yeah
oh
[ __ ]
did i switch out the wrong one
ah god damn it
oh god circle
circle gang oh god oh god oh god
no circle gang
no
in the popcorn get out of here
spicy popcorn that sounds amazing
i want that el maco flavor do you
remember those el maco
that in popcorn
mama
oh mama
oops oh double cannon so epic
this circle is really not in our favor
huh
calm down we're in the circle
oh you can buy stuff
oh
oh oh oh
i can't see anything where are they oh
gosh
oh it's our teammate nevermind
where are they
[ __ ] them up
there you are
where are you going [ __ ]
[Music]
let's stick with that teammates
oh get [ __ ]
you're welcome teams
oh there's some sweaty battling
happening
quadruple very nice
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm stunned
[ __ ]
they got me
come on baca
well gg anyway i like the game it was
fun
all right i gotta go that was my last
game
very epic check out link in the
description if you want to download
check it out use the link
that way they know i sent you [ __ ]
oh i got the most kills most damage most
everything thank you for hanging out on
this wonderful sunday mate
see you next time
come on
oh yeah
bye
you